well it is a challenging to be here I
suppose but we think that we have a very
important message about the fact that
coal is continuing to play a big role in
the world's energy mix and that's
something that's going to continue for
this decades to come and so we think
it's very important to focus on the role
of the low emission technologies for
coal which the high efficiency plants
that are commercially available today
and work more on carbon capture and
storage which will be critical in the
decades to come why is it you think that
carbon capture and storage hasn't really
taken off in the way that everyone has
been predicting for years well I think
we've seen that government's haven't put
the same sort of support the same sort
of policy mechanisms in place for carbon
capture and storage as we've seen for
say renewables we've had a big success
success story with renewables growing
significantly in recent years but if you
look at the policy support the subsidies
have been put in place for carbon
capture and storage for example it's
been about 20 billion dollars over the
last i--sorry overall time in fact
whereas over the last 10 years we've had
about 880 billion dollars worth of
subsidies put in place for renewable
sorry with the support and the policy
direction that governments are putting
in place it's very clear that they are
signifying a role for renewables they
haven't done the same thing for carbon
capture and storage which is
disappointing and it's a challenge cause
Donald Trump during his election
campaign got squarely behind the miners
of Virginia said he was going to support
the coal industry do you take much
encouragement from that is he actually
doing things on the ground I think it is
positive to hear the president talk
about the role of coal and the role of
cleaner coal technologies he certainly
made some policy changes to support that
in the US but here in the negotiations
the u.s. today is actually running an
event looking at the role of cleaner
fossil fuel technologies including
cleaner coal Britain and Canada have
been calling for an accelerated
phase-out of coal-fired electricity
indeed they're going to repeat that at
the summit later this week how concerned
are you that other countries are going
to take note of that well there are in
fact 24 countries that have included a
role for low emissions coal technology
as part of their Paris agreement
commitments so countries like India
China many of the Southeast Asian
countries have also included a
for low-emission coal technologies as
part of their Paris climate commitment
so you know I think the coal is going to
continue to play a big role in the
world's energy mix further decades to
come and that's why it's really
important to focus on the role of the
low emission coal technologies that can
actually help reduce emissions while
also getting the affordable and reliable
electricity coming from coal you're
quite skeptical that the UK is going to
meet its targeted phase-out of
coal-fired electricity by 2025 why is
that well I think we'll see you know
what happens but we need to see
significant additions of other capacity
essentially for that to happen you know
I take the UK government at their word
that's what they say they want to do but
I think it will be a challenge and we'll
see what happens in 2025 now it's quite
ironic that this events being held in
Germany because of course Germany is
dependent on coal for getting on for
two-fifths of its energy there were
thousands of people protesting at the
weekend about Germany's coal use what
would you say to them I understand their
concern and in you're right Germany gets
about 40 percent of its electricity from
coal Germany is a country that has had
the the energy vendor it's called the
energy change which has seen huge
additions of renewable capacity wind and
solar but I think it points to the fact
that coal still does play an important
role even when we've had big additions
of wind and solar
you